Hello, hello, hello. What's up, guys?
How we doing today?
Yeah, I noticed Destiny just spent like 45 minutes arguing with
Ellie B on Twitter.
Very weird. Very weird behavior for a millionaire. Spend his
evenings arguing with um like like not that Ellie obviously like
Ellie's smart, she's like funny or whatever. Um more than a match
for Steven really in terms of the replies, but just be your payment.
Why would you just fight with some random Twitter poster? >> Donated
$3. >> I'd like to give my unconditional
>> All right. Thank you very much, Ren Ruben. I appreciate
it. Appreciate you. Massive donator, Reven Rubin. You guys don't
notice this, but $3
times every stream for like two years. That adds up to a lot
of money. Okay. Ribbon Rubin's a massive supporter. We love Reven
Rubin. You're obsess obsessed with Gnome Chsky. Okay.
Yes, sure. Yeah. Yeah. I know. Jakun Ararch, I know. I know.
Give me a second, guys. The caffeine is going to kick in. We're
going to be more upbeat in just a second here. Okay. Just waiting
for it. Just waiting for it to hit a little harder. Yeah. What's
up? How's it going? I honestly I thought about I thought about
not streaming. I thought about it even though I told you I told
you all I'd stream. Said I'm going to stream, right? But I uh
support for JTO is pivotal right now. Yes, it is. It is. I I
heard um I heard I've not seen it yet. I just got linked a clip.
Somebody told me that Destiny literally doubled down on uh saying
Hassan should be killed.
Am I Am I hearing that correctly?
That actually happened? There's no way that actually happened,
right? That he did that on YouTube that he was like, "Oh, he
said it again." There's no way he went on his YouTube channel
and said that. Is that surprising? Yeah. To say it live on YouTube
is a lot. It's a lot. A lot. I could go listen bunch of people
are soing out about irrelevant. Irele relevant was not anywhere
anywhere near as like out of pocket as some people said yesterday.
I think he had like one or two bad assumptions which is not weird
given he was like a fan of Destiny. Argued with Destiny a lot
and thought he was pretty smart. Okay. His assumptions that were
like out of out of line were not like horrifying assumptions.
This guy absolutely denounced Destiny. Walked away moment one
when he heard about this [__] dropping. Everybody
acting like he's somehow like a Destiny sweepers. They're out
of their mind. Okay,
it's pretty crazy to me. I trust me, I've had a a lot of private
conversations with our relevant. Okay, I trust him completely.
He's not like some kind of dusty sweeper. Not at all. Okay.
Not even a little bit. He was insanely reaching. Except he said
that was like a skitso theory where he was insanely reaching
and said he didn't think it was likely. Yeah. And like let's
be real, all of us went through different different uh time periods.
We're like, "Dude, there's no way this guy's like losing it this
badly, right?" I
around the time he was like, "Yeah, J and Queen should be around
that time." I was like, "Dude, there's no way he's there's no
way he's losing it this badly, right? There's no way." And then
it's just been steadily down from there. He said it's somewhere
here. I have somebody sent me some leftovers H3 clips. Okay.
Some uh some snark subreddit posts. All right. I've heard snarking
is all the rage these days. Any snarkers in the chat? We get
some people snarking. Any snarkers? Snarkers. Hello. Can I get
a three in the chat if you're snarking right now, guys? Anyone
doing some snarking in the chat? Threes if you're snarking. Honestly,
it's just like it's so people just make up these terms. I don't
know.
Anti-fan snarker. I'm just going to come up with a label that
I can negatively load as much as possible so that nobody listens
to you. It's so transparent, too. I just don't get how it I don't
get it, dude. Rhox, you are so far ahead of the curve on the
snark thing. You were like so far ahead of the curve.
You are basically a middle-aged woman. That's how far ahead of
the snarking curve you are. You registered Jtock Snark within
like 3 months of me starting streaming. That's crazy.
That's crazy precience right there. Okay. To know that that was
going to be critical right away. That's nuts. What am I looking
at here?
Guys, like the blastoff tweet with the Connor meme. Like the
blastoff tweet. Engage with the blastoff tweet. Link the stream
links under the blastoff tweet. Okay, let's go.
What's happening in that screenshot? I don't know what somebody's
saying here. Where's my There it is. This should switch.
Did it switch? It did. It did. It did. Yeah. Like the blastoff
tweet. Engage with the blastoff tweet. Post the links to the
kick stream under the blastoff tweet.
What year were you top DJ? Uh, last year. Last year we were top
DJ. DJer of the year apparently.
I don't know why that community voted for a known anti-semite
for DG of the year. That seems kind of weird. Like probably they
wouldn't want to do that, but you know. You know, dude. Okay.
Um, man,
one of the things we're going to have to do here is go over this
like new pixie filing for Destiny going on the food shop stream.
If anyone's got that clip of Desty going and leaking that in
the food shop stream, it seems like he's actually going to be
in some fairly serious trouble. Okay, well, we got a Sick Unchained
Sick Unchained tweet. Sick Unchained is my favorite Snark poster.
Okay, he's always posting Snark. Wait, what is this? Here is
Destiny talking about checking out a 16-year-old dingled
their a gun range together. The way that the recoil would travel
through her body would make her app jiggle in the most delicious
way.
wait. What? This person was really 16 at the time. Actually,
what? This is new
Some new Destiny lore right now. What am I reading? I'm reading
a sick Listen, I'm not opening up a sick post on stream, okay?
Before I read it. Are you serious? Of course, I'm not opening
up a sick post on stream before I read it off stream. And make
sure there's not somebody's docs in it or that it's not like
Yeah. Basically, just to make sure that guy doesn't give a Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna read the sick post off stream, dude. There's
no way.
There's no way this is real. >> I'm scared. Hold on.
>> All right. Hold on. Hold on. I need to pause the music
and turn this up.
>> There's no There's no way. >> I'm scared. Hold
on. He's going to say something to me. >> Here, right?
When you're um when you first learn how to, it's usually better
to in the um isos stance, right? Both arms are even. Your entire
body is like straight, right? your legs are lined up with your
shoulders and and your right out in front of you like this. But
the way I didn't know this until I started watching her, but
um what happened was when she when she fired, right, when she
was shooting like this and she shot, the way that the recoil
traveled through her body would make her abs jiggle in the most
delicious way. Oh my god, it was the most beautiful sight I've
ever seen in my entire life. I don't know how it worked, but
just every
this is this How old is that girl? The the girl's apparently
16.
Is this true? Chad, is this real? Chad Chad, is this real? Is
this person actually 16 when this clip took place?
There's no way, >> Shot. The way that her body absorbed
the recoil, there was like that jiggle every shot. Oh my [__]
god. It was the best [__] thing I've ever seen in
my life. Holy [__]
>> I don't know. >> Oh, I like Dude, I really like
booties. Damn, that's beautiful. >> Oh my god, that is
[__] up. That guy. I was like 16.
Okay, I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done with streaming.
I'm done with streamers. I was like 16 when we went to the gun
show. When we went to the He's like friend zone. That's weird.
We were friends. Not like that.
He's like, what is he like 30 or >> That's kind of weird.
I'll be real. It's a It's a little weird. >> Did you watch
it? >> Isn't it creepy as He's just a little crazy. I don't
know. He was friends with the
uh Mia Rose. And I guess like I don't know if they're still friends.
>> That ended Rocky. Okay, that one that one ended Rocky.
Okay, the Mia Rose one ended. Dude, how did this guy survive
like 2014?
How how the six the the girl who's 16 when he's describing how
hot she was when she was okay is laughing and going, "Yeah, I
think he was friends with like Mia Rose who he assaulted on stream."
Bro, there's no way. There's no way. >> Destiny, [__]
off. [__] off. Stop attacking me. You were talking
about my ass when I'm 16 years old. What the [__]
They said that you were
Holy.
I didn't say. Oh my god. He tried touching me. We were just friends.
Like we were both streamers and we were friends and we both >> Oh,
did they try editing the part out of the VOD where food shops
I don't know if hiding evidence is a good idea, guys. Apparently
in the food shops VOD, they edited out the part where he leaks
the stuff from the >> Your computer. >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Richie, get me a time stamp,
bro. What are you doing? What are you doing, buddy? What are
you doing, man? What are you doing? We need a time stamp there.
So, apparently, um, she deleted the VOD. No, this was the VOD.
I thought somebody's sending me the VOD, right? The full thing,
but apparently they edited out. He said they didn't capture that
part.
I think they just edited it out. Richie's telling me that it's
in the transcript. So, if you click on this, right,
>> you click on this, you go through the transcript to
show transcript.
Apparently, the transcript has not updated yet. Give me a second.
359.
Kelly's the most abusive. Oh, maybe this is maybe this is somebody
else's transcript. 359.
Oh, I didn't want to insult Kelly. Now, as the others told me,
he removed the emotes he had with my name on
3 hours 59 minutes. Oh, thank you. Okay. Jesus. 3 hours 59 minutes.
Let me see. >> Also, you mentally deficient excuse for
a human being. I'm mad about
>> I You need to give me a time stamp, Richie. I'm sorry.
This is like I'm I'm going around cuz you you linked me this.
Okay. You linked the time stamp. Where did you link it? Okay.
I need you guys to be very direct with some of this stuff. Okay.
Where is it linked? Oh, no way.
That can't possibly be the No, I don't think so.
Uh, I don't I don't think that could possibly be
Oh, no. That can't possibly be the group chat. Although, I see
a lot of the names. I see a lot of the names. Uh-oh. Who do we
know here? Who do we know? We know Spriggs. That can't be that
group chat, dude. That can't be the group chat. Hold on. I'm
not opening it on stream. Professional streamer, by the way.
Somebody's saying, "Apparently, this is um apparently this is
a link of the group chat." I don't see Destiny in this group
chat. So, how is this a leak of the group chat if Destiny's not
in this? Oh, this is the doxing,
right? This is the where the lingerie and Nico Sam and this would
be where Laundry lingerie, Nico, Sam, and Dan were talking about
doxing Hassan's dad, right?
See TC Brady, see DMAC? Why do I know DMAC? I know DMAC from
somewhere. I don't know where. So, just to be clear, somebody
said that this was Knox said this was the uh group chat or something.
This is not the group chat that they were looking for Rose in.
Okay, this is a different group chat. Is Icorus Bath in there?
He is. He is indeed. Well, let me go. Let me look at his Emory
stream. Okay, I just have to tell you guys, if you link to me,
sorry, I'm I'm uh sorry, we're looking around at who's in here.
Wait, is Dan here? No, sorry. I'm uh I'm going back and forth
between DMs and looking at like stuff linked earlier in the day.
Okay, guys, when you're linkage, link time stamps. Okay, link
time stamps >> cuz he definitely used to work work for
Austin show and
>> what is this? Kathy was on here. Leaked what? I'm looking
for where this uh where the this was leaked. I don't see it.
You know what? I have no idea what the [__] this
is. Oh well well it's like just give me a time stamp of some
kind. Kathy is everywhere. Kathy is no one. Kathy is kind of
out of their mind. I'll be honest with you. Just looking at this.
I'm trying to see. There's a lot of people here who would have
been in the um the bigger group chat too. Anyway,
that's far less interesting than I thought. 59. I don't see the
thing in the transcript either. So,
I'll be honest with you guys. This was the uh this was him actually
reading this. >> The things that came up was um I'm just
recalling I'm just recalling some things from my very very good
memory. Okay. I'm recalling from my very very good memory. All
right. >> It's funny because like so many times when um
Pixie's answering questions in court, the judge has to like interrupt.
He's like, "Wait, who sent what?" Because the case is so weird.
Like there's a part where she's talking about like sending I
guess she sent her ex all of our videos. I never knew this, but
apparently she she um did. And then she says this and judge like,
"Wait, you're saying Steven sent all of the videos of you guys
hooking up to your boyfriend?" And she's like, "No, no, I sent
them." And he's like, "Oh, why would you do that?" It's just
like so funny. It's just like so confused. Um she tried to claim
that it was like my idea, I guess, kind of to like make video
together, but it was like clearly her idea. Why do you guys keep
pinging Dan? Is he saying something? He's not showing up in my
chat. Can you Can you guys not if he's not here? >> Oh,
he's in chat. Hold on. I'm trying to >> I'm trying to remember
really really hard what was said. Okay. I think my lawyer says
something along the lines of like, "So, does that impact your
testimony at all that it was Mr. Bunnell's idea to make the video
or do you now realize that you were the one that first raised
the idea of making videos together?" And she and I think she
said something like,
>> "Oh, it was for advertise on Twitch getting clips."
Okay, I see. Did that what 7 3 minutes ago? All right. What I
claimed was that he sent me Molina's stuff and as a response
to that I was like, "Oh, do you want me uh do you want to make
stuff?" >> No, no, no. It wouldn't be for advertising on
Twitch. It would be for the his like website to go and gather
stuff for
the the advertise on Twitch that shows like the terrorist propaganda
that plays before your Twitch ad. That's it. >> Together.
Because I thought him sending Molina stuff was like, "Oh yeah,
like you know, he's into recording stuff." And then I think my
lawyer repeated, "Does it refresh your recollection that it was
your idea to actually suggest making a video with Mr. Bonell?"
And then I think, so she said something like this. Okay, she
goes, "I'm trying to think how to phrase this in a way that makes
sense." If I'm like, >> "It's not this one. It's a different
one. It's like literally just advertised on Twitch. It's just
this. It's literally like, "Oh, you're this brand?" Yeah,
it's like this brand. And then you can uh I think it's supposed
to play clips or something with those brands. I don't know. It
was just so that they could um Yeah, like report. Just do some
reporting. Boom. Boom. >> Like, all right, I'll use this
analogy. >> Here's your IP on. He has your IP now. Okay.
Unfortunate.
>> If I have like a cup of water and I drink it and I'm
like, "Oh my god, you know, water is really cool. I love water.
You know, water is awesome." And you go, "Oh, hey, do you want
some water?" Because you keep, you know, you sat here talking
about water. Is it Okay, I'm not sure how to phrase this. The
way that
and then and then I think I think I remember like is that what
she sound like? >> Yeah, something like that. Something
Yeah, something
maybe similar. Something like that. Holy [__] bro.
I can't >> dude if it's if it's cooked like that. If it's
cooked like if it's that cooked I don't like I don't Dude, [__]
No wonder that she doesn't want to release. It would be like
the biggest embarrassment she would have undertaken in a [__]
decade. Jesus. Uh
>> uh no I can think of one bigger I can think of a bigger
embarrassment she's undergone just off the top off the off off
the dome I can think of at least one thing that was more embarrassing
for Pixie than anything she could have said in an open courtroom.
Okay. That's psychotic. That's that's a psychotic >> Wait.
Okay. You know >> don't show this. This is what I'm talking
about. Do you understand?
>> Yeah I know. Okay. So okay. No it's >> No but
the whole thing is like this. The whole thing is like it's so
wacky. >> That's not >> I was so irritated when they
moved to this and I'm like yeah but I'm like there's no no duh.
They try to steal it but it's like so irritating cuz like this
is the first time we're both under >> 100% performative
from food shops. You don't say >> so we can speak to the
judge and like everything has to be out and like honest and it's
like yeah but >> oh my god dude Jesus Christ. Wait, hold
on. You know what? What's another part that bothers me? >> The
things that came up was >> Wow. Okay. All right. Hold on.
Why did I get linked this? What is this? If you're going to call
me a virtue of destiny, you are as well. JTO, not a good thing.
Did I say that? That probably tells you something that I don't
know. Y'all destiny mind raped? Nope. Good thing. Harassment
can just be emotional. Deeply unserious. Maybe. Let's move on.
I I know this one was uh in regards to who Dan would rather have
as a babysitter. You picked Destiny over me. That was up, Dan.
I'll be real with you. That was [__] up when you
said you'd rather have Destiny babysit your kids than me. Come
on, dude. Come on, dude. Anyway. Oh, we didn't even finish this.
Jesus. Okay.
All right. We're locking in. Okay. We're locking in.
You lock it in.
Be ready to go. All right. Going to watch this girl cringe at
Destiny a little bit more. All right. This girl who was 16 when
she went and Destiny was super attracted to her. kind of just
driving home the exact point that most people have been making
about Rose. You know, >> both like the same game. >> Keep
watching.
>> That is he donated $3 and said it was >> Shut
up. >> Don't Don't do that. Don't do that. That is [__]
>> Oh yeah. >> Right to bear arms. I let Destiny
>> No, he didn't teach me how to suck the D. I'm done.
Oh yeah,
>> I have you. >> I see. These could be anybody.
These could be anybody. These could be anybody. Definitely weird.
Giers, but
>> No,
no.
>> Um, no, no, no, no, no. Guys, listen. This is just a
Streamlabs. Anybody could donate through this and use any name,
okay? You can't take it seriously. These names aren't 100%. Um,
almost certainly people would use other like names from that
community. So, just don't take the name seriously. >> I
don't know where it was.
>> Okay, so a dad, thank you so much for subscribing. Ignore
that last donation in the last two hours on this stream. Great,
Dad. Glad to see you're watching at this magnificent time. >> From
animal on the >> shut up. >> He's 31 now. would have
been 15 years ago if she were 16. Actually, this would have had
to happen in 2010.
It's not unbelievable that it would h happen in 2010. What do
we see here? This is Dota. This is a very old Dota UI. Can I
see that from Oh, wait. Is it Dota? I'm Oh, maybe it's Counterstrike
actually. Knives. Maybe it's Counter-Strike. Looks like the Dota
UI, but
>> Wait. So, wait. So Rose was two when he was checking
out this teenager. Dude, he's been he's been in the game a long
time. Okay, that's the real reason the age gap is concerning.
All right, this guy's had
two decades to figure out how to hit on teenagers. All right,
two decades. They don't stand a chance.
Okay, dude.
Okay, I'm gonna be real with you guys. I'm going to join my open
call. I'm going to join my Colin's channel because I hoping somebody
else comes in with some energy. Here we go. We're in the channel.
I've got like content tonight, too. That's the funny thing. I've
got content to watch.
>> You got stuff. >> Destiny Minercraft just tipped
$5. >> Hold on. >> Oh, ye.
Thank you for the five. Destiny
>> You're You're just Okay. Right. >> Okay. Hold
on. Let me set some stuff up here. Okay. There's one more thing.
Here's the full story from Destiny. He describes how attractive
this teen is and how nice her ass is in detail.
Okay. When you're a new
take a girl to the gun range first learn how to shoot as you
Oh my god. It was the most beautiful. We watched this whole thing.
Okay. All right. That was funny. No more. No more of that. We're
good with We're good on that. We're good on that. Juice up. I
Dude, I I've already taken all the juice. Is there news about
Zena? Last news about Zena was she talked to Icy and said she's
retiring and that she has a record deal from a record label,
which I thought was probably not true to be honest with you,
but hard to say. What is that boys tolli thing? Uh these are
the two
prominent black members of the community photoshopped onto what
is a appears to be not even photoshopped.
They're uh they're on a an AI album. Boys to Rellies. This is
Artful. This is Rei. Okay. They they don't look anything alike.
They don't look anything alike. Okay. All right. >> I will
chill your That's just facts. Reban Ruben donated $3. Bro went
from gun range to goon range.
>> This way. Snap that way. >> Hello. Hello. Hello.
How's it going, guys?
How we doing today? How we doing? How we feeling? How's it going?
What's up? What's up? What's up? It is
Friday,
August 22nd, and oh my god, isn't it a great day?
that are you guys finding you're waking up every morning with
like a smile on your face recently? Are you finding that it's
like every day is just the best day? Every every single day is
the best day, isn't it? God. Every It's just I wake up and cool
things are happening. Every single day. This is like This is
like It was like This is exactly what it was like growing up
in the early 2000s, okay? It's exactly what it was like. Just
every day was awesome. Awesome stuff was happening all the time.
Get a bunch of stuff from like McDonald's or Wendy's for a dollar.
Okay. The world was awesome. It was just based in every way.
All right. >> This wasn't part of the Epstein files, but
it correlates. Okay. All right. I've been dropping banger memes
because of all this. I That's how I feel, too. Okay. It's all
funny. It's all funny. It's all there. It's God.
What a great day. What a great day today is. What a great day.
What a great week it's been.
man. I didn't even I watched this whole Willie video already.
I hope you guys don't mind. Little pre-watching, okay? But I
went through and did a whole tweet thread with uh just corresponding
to Ellie's tweets.
If you guys don't remember, we covered the Ellie thread yesterday.
Okay. I I've also been told that it's Eli. Eli Eli B again. Okay.
Eli, we covered the Eli thread. Okay. Let me uh let me see if
I can pull that back up.
>> Oh, I got to reset these meters,
guys. We've got a lot today. Okay, we've got all of this. We're
hopefully going to get some counterpoints content. Okay, we'll
hope hopefully get to that. We've got the Willie video itself.
We've got some Destiny logs from today. We've got Destiny's stream
to review where he talks about this a little bit. Okay, we've
got all of this and more. It's all here. And also, if we happen
to go long, I've got the Merc content queued up. Okay, I've got
it. I've got it ready to go. All right, we're ready to go. We
got it. It's It's locked in. All right, it's locked in. Destiny
is visibly nervous in his streams now. It's all coming together.
Well, well well.
Ah, finally somebody posted it. Okay, I hate to I hate to be
the guy, but dude, it's I have to Okay, it's like I don't know if
I can pull this up on Twitch. You know what it is what it is.
This meme is it unfortunat I didn't want to use it for the blastoff
tweet, okay? But it goes so hard. It goes so hard.
It goes unbelievably hard. Okay, it goes unbelievably hard. Am
I supposed to feel sympathy for like for the people this like
dude that this guy's been in here talking all kinds of talking
about how my partner is going to do like he's so he's so full
of him. Anybody who virtue signals over this this is just funny.
Okay. It's just funny. That's that's all it is. Now it's time
for a celebration. It is time for a celebration. It's not a coincidence
that Destiny immediately ended his stream when you went live.
Well, I'll tell you what he's hoping for, okay? Cuz this is Destiny's
playbook in general. He's hoping I'll make some minor mistake
that he could try to like blow up into something, right? He's
hoping I'll, you know, make some minor misstep and and then he
can like focus on that. That's what he's hoping for. But it's
not going to matter. Okay. I can never make a minor mistake as
big as the one he did. Okay. I can't. Unfortunately, he has made
the cardinal minor mistake. Okay. Oof. Yeah, I was not even paying
attention. Okay, guys. We got the blastoff tweet here. All right.
What are you talking about? Anti-fans, snark communities, gay
stock. Hassan, just put the hard drives in the bag. We don't
have all day.
That's the blastoff tweet, guys. It's pinned in the chat. Engage
with the blastoff tweet. Like the blastoff tweet. We love the
blastoff tweet. Lets everybody know where the stream's at. All right.
This is uh what an auspicious day. I'm just wondering, are you
banned from Destiny's chat? Isn't it weird that his mods banned
loads of people here a few days before he started to come into
your chat? Uh I don't know. I'm probably I'm almost certainly
banned from his chat, right? I think I have to be. Let me check.
I'll check in on another monitor. Give me two seconds.
I'm banned from that chat. Yeah, I'm banned from that chat. Unlucky.
All right. So, do we have some stuff to go into before we get
to the Willy Mack tweet? Maybe we'll go over this Ellie thing
as well real quick on Twitter. Okay. Okay, that's why I watched
the Willy Mack video was because I watched the Ellie B or sorry,
I was thinking about the Ellie B tweets when it first came out
and I was just like, "Dude, Eli, Eli B. Eli B. Eli, Eli, Eli.
It's going to take a while. So, I thought it was Ellie because
Eli I thought was the masculine name, but it is Eli. Yeah. No,
Peanob, you're not banned for no reason. You're banned because
his admins went and banned everybody who chats here from his
chat. You chat in this chat, you get banned in his chat. Which
ironically actually cut down on the amount of DJers who are willing
to come in here and and just try to stir. So cool, cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. You love to see it. Uh, hold
on. I don't know if I have that clip. Neo, I think I'm going
to go through his whole stream. All right. All right. I think
I'm going to go through the whole stream. I think we're going
to do basically like the whole thing while he's talking about
the the drama. Okay. The drama.
All right. Okay. We'll start off with these tweets. >> Let
me go find them. Yeah, let me go find them. Okay. So, I pre-watched
the video. So, if you guys don't know, the punchline of the Willie
Mack video is Destiny essentially sent Willie Mack evidence that
he still retained these videos. Um, not going to go too much
into the legality of retaining. It seems like like I'm not sure.
Uh, Eli actually saves us again. Hold on. Eli actually saves
us again. tweets out the analogy that I had kind of come up with
uh not like independently, but it's like um why was there a dead
body and a bloody knife buried in my backyard? Well, I thought
if the police ever found out about the murder, they might want
to see the evidence. Oh, Jesus.
Right. It's like it's like, okay, and also people shouldn't really
soy out about him about that excuse, right? Oh, it's like dude,
so about the crime. Okay, there's there's like actual crimes
there, right? That's the thing.
Shut it down. Trust me, I believe that's that that's cured at
this point. Okay, that's cured at this point. It has to be cured
at the point where he goes and talks to Willie Mac. Okay, and
I'm not kidding you. He goes to talk to Willy Mack and goes,
"Look at the file name of the CP that I got from her." And takes
a screenshot of VLC with the title and the date in the title
2022 20 uh sorry, 2022 0814 August 14th, 2022. essentially confirming
in that timestamp
that she would have been a minor and he sends a picture of the
video to Willie Mac. Okay, I don't know what this this has to
be like. The only possible way for you to still think Destiny
is smart is you have to think Destiny has 10,000 IQ and actually
he's foreseen 3,000 years into Earth's future and he is avoiding
an apocalypse of the human race by by doing this now. Somehow
this sacrifice leads like the butterfly effect to the human race
avoiding an extinction event. Okay, that's like the only way
you could possibly interpret this is like Destiny having any
control or doing anything intelligent here. That's like the end.
That's it. Okay, there's just no other possible way. You can't
cope about it anymore.
It's insane. So anyway, he sent that stuff to Willy Mack. And
if you don't remember when he was talking to Eli,
she says only one of us can make that Oh, sorry. Actually, I've
been thinking this over. She's talking about Solo. I would like
to see the police look into this if for no reason other than
he could exploiting be exploiting other girls. Only one of us
can make that happen. want redemption, Stephen? Go to the police
tomorrow and give them everything you have. And he responds,
I have nothing to give them. I have nothing to give them. And
then we also get the Willy Mack logs of him saying, "Look at
this. Look at this video she sent me. Look at this screenshot
from the video she sent." Brother, brother, I don't
I don't I don't know. Okay. Okay.
That's not all of it. Okay. We also have uh we have the Willy
Mack logs here. I think he sent his entire logs. I think he put
them out. Let's take a look at this real quick. Let's take a
quick look. Uh, birthday would be October
2004.
October 2004. So, let's see here. August 20th, 2025. Willie Max
sends a DG Snark Snark post to Destiny saying Rose confirmed
to be 17. Hey, so I'm reading seeing this Reddit thread. Any
insights into if this is true or at all or not? If if that's
actually her or if he knew her age or not. This is going to get
bigger than it is now or bigger than it is right now. Hold on
one second. This getting bigger than it is right now. I mean,
she told me she was 19 and uh and she was in college when we
were chatting. Lol. If she was actually 17, then she should be
asking why that solo guy had recorded like 60 GB of porn with
her, plus all the other guys she recorded stuff with. I'm pretty
sure even Solo said she lied about her age to me in that KF thread
somewhere. Okay. Willie responds, I do kind of remember covering
that in my vid. Yeah, he said that you he said that you didn't
know. Lol. This is uh this is cringe but and then he posts some
some logs here. Okay, some logs there. Is this the next Okay,
weird overlap here. Okay, so like even in our logs I'm referring
to as a 19-year-old. I think Solo even posted these. Uh William
says, "In my Kelly Gene video, in my video, Kelly Gene makes
the argument that there's a message of you saying, "Do you have
an ID?" And she said, "No, Kelly never proved this to me." Surely
Destiny wouldn't go on to prove out the Twitter DMs or confirm
the Twitter DMs here, right? I actually don't recall this being
in the video, but obviously that if that pops up, that's a big
deal. I thought she showed me a student ID or something, but
I can never know about those messages because one our first ones
were on Twitter and they deleted their account. But Tinder does
some kind of Oh, you have your side of the messages though, do
you not? Would he not have if he went and did like a data dump?
Would he not have his messages? I think he would, right?
Wouldn't he? But Tinder does some kind of age check. I don't
remember if they This is a lie. This is a lie. This is a lie
that Willie ran with. By the way, this is a lie that Willie ran
with and supported without doing any factchecking at all because
of course Willie maybe maybe after this conversation Willy's
finally been broken out of well everything Destiny says is true
but at the time he was not broken out of it and he was just like
yeah Tinder apparently does some sort of age verification.
Yes, exactly. Cyberdrifter they can do age verification now but
they didn't do it in 2021 2022. That's true. Yes.
So he tries the same lie as before. He's trying the same Jedi
mind trick as before on Willie. And Willie says, "I looked into
this when I made my vid. I don't think that it is require that
is required." That would be horrible if you put that in your
video. Wait, what was the segment from his video? Hold on. Am
I crazy? I could have sworn in his video. He was like, "I looked
into it. It seems like they did age verify."
Hold on. There's Hold on. There's no way. Right now I have to
go find the Willie video. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Which Willie
video was it in? Number one or number two? Give me a second.
Let's find it. Oh, this music is really obtrusive, though. Give
me a second. Put on some quieter instrumental only music in the
background. There we go. >> I want to preface this video
by stating I was >> Hold on. Okay. Confronting Destiny
on his crimes.
We have Tinder here. No, it would be in the second video, right?
The Kelly Jean video. Video where he interviews Kelly. I believe
that'll be this one. Content cop Destiny. >> Back to the
death threat in a minute. I just want to address an >> Let's
check this out. We got uh we got Tinder here, right?
is wrong. >> Was now in an impossible position.
>> Hold on. We'll find it. We'll find it. I just have to
see what Willie said. Maybe maybe I'm misremembering what Willie
said. It's possible, right? Where did my transcript just go?
Just bounced away.
>> I think Tinder to find hook up some and Tinder does
um is an 18 or older app. >> And Destiny sent me messages
he had with Rose and her talking about using Tinder. I haven't
used Tinder in like 8 years, so I don't know. Google says it
verifies age. There needs to be more tangible evidence right
now. The worst
>> Okay, hold on
then. Willy's logs here don't really make sense. Hey, I looked
What?
Appears Tinder verifies age. That's what he says in the video.
Tinder some I looked into this when I made my vid. I don't think
that is required. Then why did you say otherwise in your video?
Why did you just go Google says they verify age? That's like,
does that not seem weird that he just he like lied to Destiny
about what he found for his video? Or he just or he found this
and he didn't put it in the video for some reason. I looked into
this when I made my vid. I don't think that is required, but
I don't know. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years. What do
you mean he looked into it after the video? He says, "I looked
into this when I made my video."
What? That's crazy. Do you see that? He says, "I looked into
this and I don't think that is required, the age verification
thing." But in his video, he says the age verification is required.
So either he knew that at the time and he lied. He just said
well no no it seems Google just says it is required which was
why would you do that or he's just lying here? I don't I don't
know which one it is. J stop. You know full well he watched Augie
taking him to task and he's now changed his position. Well he
hasn't changed his position at all. His position is crystallized
in his video. Right. Oh no. Destiny continues.
I want this clarified. Was there ever a time you asked for her
ID because you were suspicious of her being a minor and she refused
to show you? No. I don't think so. That would have been a super
red flag. No, I don't think so. Then say, "No, you can go look
at your DMs, Destiny. You have the ability to do this." Destiny
will go on to say, "I saved all of my messages with her." You
don't have to say, "I think don't think so." You can say what
the truth is. You saved all of your messages,
right? Did you not save all of your messages? Is that not what
you said? We don't have to do what you think. You can just go
figure it out. I don't think age verification is required in
the USA. It's something you can opt into, I think. But again,
I'm not sure. Also, you never showed me her Tinder profile or
anything from it. Just say you her saying she used it. Okay.
Yeah, that's also true. I'm not going to make a vid on any of
this because right now there isn't proof that you knew or are
suspicious. But if that exists, that's really bad. Like you said,
super red flag. These are all Tinder the Tinder mentions. There's
no ID mentioned in our logs. But like I said, I'm pretty sure
that first convo happened on Twitter and since they deleted the
account, I don't have access to it. I'm pretty confident if you
do a full data dump from Tinder or sorry from Twitter as like
a GDPR thing, they would give you those messages. They would
have that data stored because I think you can undo your deletions,
right? Like you when you deactivate your account or delete it,
I think you can undo that for some amount of time. Anyway, it's
kind of crazy that there are like 10 plus parties all involved
in creating with this person if she is less than 18 and her boyfriend
Solo, the guy who I sure sounds like Desi's got to go to the
cops if he's got evidence of this, right? like he's got evidence
of this somehow which he I think he doesn't realize he's clearly
talking about seeing let's just let's just soak in what he is
saying there right there are like 10 plus parties all involved
in creating with this person he is saying he has seen at least
10 different dudes this minor that is what he is saying he's
going that is what he is saying there like pretty objectively
no that's wild
I'm just I'm just throwing it out there that's crazy that's a
crazy thing to say anyway okay we keep we keep going and How
did he get that evidence? It seems pretty clear what he's admitting
to here. Okay. I wonder if the reason the solo dude never leaked
any identifying info about her was because he was worried he'd
get caught. Bro, you're in such a weird LFAO. I mean, if you
didn't know and you asked, then fair. She's take she's talking
about college here. Is Solo not her age? My guess is he's around
her age. I don't know 100%.
Uh, and she was in college the whole time. Yeah, but I guess
it's possible she went in one year early. It's fun. Uh, it's
fine. It was fun. Other than that, I'll see if I can salvage
any of the recordings my boyfriend made for you. I didn't notice
this until way later, but the videos she'd record with other
guys, the file names are like screen recording blah blah blah
blah blah. And this screen recording
the date on it, bro. And he sends a he sends a picture of VLC
having this video open. Now, couple things about this. Okay,
one, I really want to reach out to Willie, okay? Because it's
possible that something happened here. Okay, it's possible that
when he went to go share this image, he clicked copy link and
copied that that file over, right? If you do that in Discord,
it will autombed.
But
if he's autombedding from one of those other group chats, okay,
one of the group chats that were made uh on December 3rd or December
4th, that is to my mind, if he is sending this screen cap, that
is proof in my mind that the the group chat to find Rose exists,
right? Absolutely.
So Willie needs to go and copy link here and and put that link
publish that link on Twitter. Okay,
we need to we need to ask for this. You guys all understand what
I'm saying, right? You know what I'm talking about. Uh, Alex
Gekcko tweeted about this. Let me go find the Alex Gekcko tweet.
Who dumped these messages? Willie did. Hold on. Where's the Where's
the Alex Gekcko thing? This guy right here. Okay. So, he posts
this this thing from uh from KF directly. And basically, like
I forget if it's blue or red, but one of these is the uh the
channel ID. And you can look up through a third party site, the
snow stamp site, to see when the channel ID was created. If these
channel IDs matched, if if this same channel ID existed, right,
for the attachment sent to Willie,
that would be proof in my mind that this is a group chat purely
to find Rose. Why would Willie dump these messages when it doesn't
really absolve him? Because I think he knows Destiny's totally
going down and I think he is in self-preservation mode. That
is what I think is happening here, right? I think he was perfectly
fine trading messages with Destiny. He's perfectly fine being
in that guy's camp before, but at this point, he knows that this
guy's and and this is him jumping off the boat. Okay. Yeah, this
is the rat leaving the sinking ship. Absolutely. Yes, JTO. Destiny
kind of admits to this on his stream. He said he kept the videos
so we could watch them and try to find her. He's the server is
real.
Uh, dude, what's the the issue here, Jacob, is not really that
he was trying to find her, although that's weird. The issue would
be if he did have and he had reason to believe he was informed
that this person might be a minor and then he decided to disseminate
parts of those videos to people. I don't know how he is not mega
at that point. If he did that, that is insane. That is the Destiny
Defender arc. That is it's like so beyond over at that point.
It's crazy. Yes. Yes. Yes. Really soy guy. Like if this existed
and he was posting the stuff in in there. Oh my god, that's crazy.
He knows he's that's why he ended stream early. Well, we'll have
to go take a look at that stream and see exactly what's there.
I That's
I have a hard time. Dude, we're hitting one of those poories
in our shoes eight months ago now. Yeah, that's basically what
it was is you hadn't seen some of the decisions. But like here's
the thing. This was made in December. These poor decisions seem
to have been made in December. Like these are old really bad
decisions. So with Solo, the man that destroyed his career, also
his I don't I don't know what the arrangement was there. Okay,
I don't know what that what was going on there. Okay, we've gone
through a lot of these logs. Her boyfriend was recording recording
these on Skype calls. That's just absolutely insane to think
about him doing all this if she was 17. That is not a defense,
bro. And he told you she was 17, so it's not a defense to continue
to send the the video like video thumbnails of this stuff around.
Willie says, "If you're sending me this, I'm guessing you stole
that video." And Destiny immediately gets defensive. Uh, depends
on why you're asking, but yes, I created a copy of all of our
messages and everything when that court case started. Bruh, there's
been allegations since at least my last vid that she was underage,
and you still have potential CP of her. So, this is Willie showing
his IQ again. Okay, this is showing his IQ. Bro, why didn't you
just like immediately delete the evidence of a crime? Now, I
think there's a lot of things you could you could say to Destiny
here, right, about like, I don't think he should be keeping that.
I think you should probably turn that over to the cops. You should
probably turn that over to a lawyer. You should probably I don't
think you should be in possession of that cuz obviously when
he retained possession of it, he decided he was going to disseminate
parts of those videos. It seems clear to me he just did it with
Willie Mack. We have evidence of that, right? No, I've watched
the whole Trust me, Black Irish, I understand that some states
did it eventually, but it's just it's like in 2021, 2022, there
was no forced age verification.
Certainly not where she was. I know that. I don't need backups
of that right now. I know. I know that for a fact. A fact. All
right, dude. The cope is going to be so funny today. Some some
logs here from DGG that just got sent. Okay, Destiny, they keep
saying they won't pursue it because she's underage. They they
keep saying you won't pursue it because she's underage. Desi,
is there any way to fight back? Desi Willy Mack throwing you
under the bus. Desi Willie is literally throwing you under the
bus. Desi, he's saying you are sending he you are sending you
CP. Okay, this person is clearly having a meltdown and can't
type correctly. He's literally saying you sent him CP in this
video. He's literally saying you sent him CP and are hiding it.
It's Jover. He's literally accusing you of having child. Hassan
is going to watch this. This is the mind of the DJer, by the
way. This is the mind.
Destiny. Hassan's definitely going to watch this and make fun
of you. Destiny. Destiny. Hassan's gonna make fun of you. Hassan,
Destiny, Hassan's gonna make fun of you.
This is This is a real This is real true messages right here.
This is like the worst case scenario, guys. Hassan gets a W.
The worst case scenario. Destiny, go over the Willy Mack vid
and get your narrative out. Destiny, yes. You need to respond
to this video. It's literally insane. He completely throws you
under the bus and says you have CP. Shows a different screenshot.
Destiny, debate him.
Destiny, debate him. Debate him. Destiny, you got to debate him
now. Destiny, debate him now.
It's our only option. The damage will be done. The video is [__]
insane, bro. What is the the video is totally in line with all
of the evidence currently released that like this this Discord
existed, this Discord or Discord channel group chat existed to
try to find Rose that he was sending in there. It's all in line
with all of that stuff. It sucks because we can't verify that
email. We can't verify the Twitter messages, right? But there's
so many pieces of evidence around it that seem to corroborate
like that. This this group chat was made. The only Willie Mack
dude. Yes, that was an that was another Alex Gekkmo banger today.
Okay, you guys aren't following Alex Gekckmo. I recommend he's
he's very good. All right. I used to not be a fan of me, but
hey, we we let it all go. Okay. But your honor, have you considered
that Hassan [__] went to a brothel? My favorite part
of Destiny's stream today is when he spent 20 minutes reading
what his chat was relaying about Willy's 4-minute video instead
of watching it. He'd always been so willing to watch Willie video
videos before. Curious, dude. I don't get why Desi was looking
for Rose with that Discord crew. I have no idea, dude. I I don't
know. I legitimately don't know. He's got a ton of money. I don't
know why he wouldn't just go hire a private investigator, right?
That's one party.
What does he What did Destiny used to tell people about those
big conspiracies, the big sprawling conspiracies? Well, there's
no reason to believe that these are true or that they really
exist or that they're real. There's no reason to believe that
guys because so many people would have to be in the know that
somebody would blow the whistle, right? Like I understand you
might have a private eye, you might have a PI that you don't
necessarily trust or but like at least that's one point of failure.
You're going to start a group chat with 10 points of failure
and start linking this kind of [__] in there. That's
crazy cuz he's light Yagami. He doesn't need help like that.
Just his minions. Well, dude, no. Don't worry. Don't worry, Jake
event. Don't worry. We're going to get to the VOD. We're going to
get to everything, okay? We'll get to everything today. It's
all so good. Without further ado, though, let's actually fire
this Willie video up. Let's fire it up. Let's check it out. We
went through the logs.
>> We'll actually check out >> reported Destiny to
the police. This >> I reported Destiny to the police. All
right, let's check it out. >> I reported Destiny to the
police. This is not clickbait and entirely has to do with the
DMs he sent me. A few days ago, a Reddit post showed that >> it
will just be your pay
donated $5. I don't get how the solo logs get into the civil
case. And it's not questioned diffro
like why wasn't that escalated in the legal case to law enforcement?
>> Um why wasn't something escalated? Well, oh h man, I'm
just telling you I think people are very shocked that Willie
went to the cops. And I I've seen some tweets that are saying
things like, "Well, thank God that Willie finally somebody finally
went to the cops about this guy." Okay? And all I can really
say to that is, "Hey, idiots,
somebody already went to the cops about this guy." Okay? Like,
please stop please stop saying like, "Oh, I I can't believe nobody's
gone to the cops." No. No. Okay. Anyway, we can we can continue.
Thank you for the five. C Samony, thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Okay. Uh I I it's shocking to me that Willie is just putting
this in his video. I feel like I can watch this. I personally
would have probably blurred this person's face out. I I legitimately
don't know. I didn't notice that. I listened to this the first
time he put this person's face on the screen. I actually feel
bad that he did that now. I don't know why he just did that.
It's Hold on. and entirely has to do with the DMs he sent me.
A few days ago, a Reddit post showed that the girl Destiny shared
Pixie's nudes with was seemingly confirmed to be 17 years old
due to her getting doxed. There is almost a 0% chance that she
was not 17 during that time. So, I Okay, I don't know if he did
more of this in the video. He probably just shouldn't uh he probably
shouldn't have done that. I know exactly what his rationale would
be, too, cuz I've seen some other people say this. Okay, I don't
know how to tell people this. The DG Stark subreddit is far less
public than Kiwi Farms would be. Okay, Kiwi Farms. If you if
you don't want to post evidence because it's on Kiwi Farms, but
you're willing to go to a subreddit with like a hundred people
following it and post evidence from there, you're your brain
is broken. You don't understand what it means to like have privacy,
right?
So, I think I see some people run with this that it's like, oh,
well, it's on Reddit now and so I can just like talk about it.
It's like, no, no, no, no. It's on a niche subreddit. All right.
And and it's not if you if you have no qualms about posting it,
you should have no qualms going and getting it from like KF or
something. Okay, that's just facts. Uh Geeky Candy, thank for
the 10 gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you for the 10. The
quick tenor. I'm going to add two hours to the stream and I'm
going to probably not worry too much about these meters for the
rest of the stream here. 5 hours 30.
Thank you very much, Geeky Candy. I appreciate it. I'll reset
those. >> What I usually do and reached out to get a comment.
He said the girl Rose told him she was 19 and in college at the
time and that the leaker Solo, who is her ex-boyfriend, confirmed
that she lied about her age to him. This is true. In similar
scandals, this is where people usually argue, is he lying? Did
he actually know the age? Is it his fault if he was catfish?
I usually wait for all the details
here. I think we have enough details to go, well, he certainly
didn't do his due diligence. He certainly he certainly didn't
actually take any precautions to make sure this wasn't the case.
All right. details to come out before I comment. This is not
why I went to the police. It's because >> Oh, hold on.
Uh, Soapbox Society, thank you for the 10 gifted. Appreciate
it. Appreciate it. >> Uh, I might start muting some notifications
for a little bit and maybe replaying them, guys. We'll see. Okay,
we'll see. Let me pull this back just a little bit here. >> Was
her ex-boyfriend confirmed that she lied about her age to him.
This is true. In similar scandals, this is where people usually
argue. Is he lying? Did he actually know the age? Is it his fault
if he was catfish? I usually wait for all the details to come
out before I comment. This is not why I went to the police. It's
because he continued to write, "I didn't know this until way
later, but the video she recorded with other guys, the file names
are like screen recording." >> Uh, yeah. Thank you very
much for the >> Shows me a screenshot of the top of a video
clip and says her boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls.
That's absolutely insane to think about him doing all of this
if she was 17. Well, this is insane to me because he's saying
Rose's boyfriend recorded CP while sending me a screenshot. >> He
like doesn't understand. Somehow Destiny is like lost the ability
to understand that like once you're notified she might be under
18 that like continuing to share any elements of these videos
is probably to do. >> God just tipped $5.
Further proof that enlightened atheism isn't a path to moral
behavior.
>> Lucifer is waiting for his new playmate.
>> Thank you. Thank you for that. We're going to actually
turn the donos down for the rest of the stream. Well, for at
least a little bit. I'll maybe go back and play them two hours
or something. Remind me. I'll go back and play all of the donuts.
I'll replay them all, but thank you very much. Okay, thank you
very much, God. Appreciate it. I'm going to turn I'm going to
turn the donuts down. I just want to be able to go through this
stuff. Okay, so that that [__] interrupts sometimes.
I do appreciate all the money. I'm not angry at you guys. Thank
you very much for donating, but I do want the content to flow.
And it is it is a little hard to have it flow when the donors
are coming in. That's all. If you want to wait until I'm actually
going through donos to donate, that's also fine. Really appreciate
you guys. Love you guys. All right, going back >> recording
these on Skype calls. That's absolutely insane to think about
him doing all of this if she was 17. Well, this is insane to
me because he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP while sending
me a screenshot of the alleged CP. So, I asked to confirm if
he just did that. If you were sending me this, I'm guessing you
still have that video. Best depends on why you're asking, but
yes, I created copies of all of our messages and everything when
that court case started. Just to be clear, he's admitting to
having alleged CP downloaded on his computer. He literally has
the video open as I'm talking to him. I go >> I believe
there was basically every reason to believe this before the Willie
Mack DMs came out, right? Like we knew he had her. We knew he
talked about having downloading her of viewing it, right? And
asking her for more. All of those logs existed. You put that
together with the fact that she was 17 at the time of the DMs.
It's not hard to understand what happened, right? These DMs factually
don't add very much. That it is stark though. I will say I do
appreciate that it is stark here that you get him sending the
images, right? You get him actually sending these images, actually
showing that yes, I did indeed. Oh, I'll turn it up for you guys.
I did indeed keep these videos and I am propagating like more
details like screen caps, screen caps from them, titles from
them, everything. >> Bro, there's been allegations at least
since my last video that she was underage and you still have
potential CP of her. He replies, I have an obligation to preserve
relevant evidence except >> this is this is the moment
the moment where Willie M Willie M's conditioning broke. Okay,
this is the moment he realized he had to flee the plantation.
Was like, "Dude, I I said that you she might have been underageed.
Like, and you still kept the port of her? You're like you you're
like sending me screen caps of the port of her?" And he he like
it actually broke and he like realized, "Oh, oh, maybe this guy
isn't right about everything." So, I created backups of all of
the important/relevant conversations. He continues, "I don't
think I'm allowed to delete it. Lol. I don't know if it counts
as hiding/destroying evidence." And I reply, "Talk to a lawyer.
That seems crazy to me. >> Who keeps this sort of stuff
on their computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed to
or not? Isn't that something you want to confirm? >> Oh
my god. Could you imagine if Andy B didn't know about this stuff?
Could you
Do you guys think Andy B knows?
>> I continued. You just let me know you have CP videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still have them. Do you see how this is? So now
I've confirmed that this guy has child on his computer. In my
8 years of reaching out to people over allegations, I've never
had anyone admit that to me. The last message he sent me was
one. I don't even know 100% of her age was legitimately less
than 18 when these were taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure
if he has child on his computer. He's just 99% sure. Got it.
Two, I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to preserve, dude.
Uh, and as I pointed out, okay, I did this on on Twitter. So
as as was pointed out the date stamp on the video is literally
literally from after she or sorry before she was 18. So he says
I don't know but then when you look at the video title it says
August 14th 2022.
So if that date that if it's if 104 if October 20 October 2004
is actually her birthday her birth month then she's absolutely
a minor in this screen recording and he knows that and he is
still sending the title from it and not paying any attention
to what he's sending. By the way the date of these DMs is August
20th. Like Willie is saying hey it seems to be proven that she's
17 now. What the dude? And instead of like doing anything to
look into this, validate anything, he just goes, "Well, here's
a video from August 2022 where like I don't know if she was 18
here." No, you do know that if assuming this isn't all, you know,
assuming the 0001% chance isn't there that this is all like somehow
elaborately made up, right? You do know that she's 17. You do
know that she's a minor. You literally know that. He's probably
rock hard when he's sending them. So, probably not thinking about
Jesus Christ. Geeky Candy. Jesus.
Holy. Huh. So like even the things he's saying to Willie directly
are like either lies or he has lost the ability to like he's
lost the ability to evaluate this situation at all. >> Stuff
related to my court case. I've talked about it with my lawyer
already specifically with regards to the Rose stuff. So he went
from I don't know if I >> So he says he told Andy B about
it. Okay. He says he told Andy B and Andy B said you hold on
to that CP buddy. Now, what I'm less certain Andy B would have
said was you hold on to that CP and if you need to disseminate
that to a group of a dozen people, not including you. If you
need to do that, then that's okay, too. You just go ahead and
disseminate that bad boy. Okay? You hold on to it and then you
send it to whoever you want. I'm pretty sure Andy B didn't tell
him this. If I had to guess, I'm pretty sure Andy B is going
to be pretty pretty contankerous to find out that Destiny was
sending screen caps and/or clips from these videos to people
in a group chat. Okay? There's no universal lawyer would ever
tell him to hold on to it. I don't know, Benji. I don't know
for 100%. Okay. But to me, I don't know why you would do that
on a personal level. I don't know why you wouldn't go to the
cops if you suspected this, right? And say, "Hey, uh, like that
to me feels like the way to do this." What what actually happens
when he says like, "Oh, I was told I could do this." And he holds
on to it. In my mind, it's very obvious what he's trying to do
is not get in trouble for deleting evidence if it does come out
that she's 18, but also not report it to the cops and potentially
get himself in trouble if she is under 18, right? He's trying
to avoid getting caught and not get if he does get caught, he's
trying not to have evidence deleted so that if he does get caught,
like he's trying to play both sides of it, right? Obviously,
the the clear and honest obvious answer to everybody is the moment
you find out she might have been below 18, you go to the cops
for the exact reason that he's so out about on Twitter and pretending
is like his cover, right? For that exact reason that Solo could
have been trafficking this girl. Solo could be exploiting this
girl, right? And you don't know and you absolutely are compelled
to go to the cops in this situation. Let me go to this thread.
Right? That's that's the precise reason you have to go to the
cops as soon as you get some indication that she was under 18.
Now, I'm just talking morally,
right? I don't know if there's a legal obligation to do that.
I would think so, but I don't know for sure. Okay. I don't know
for sure. It's finally over. It really is finally over, isn't
it? It really is over. It's all He's already been visited by
the FBI. Doesn't that mean he probably lied to them? I don't
know what the That was him talking about it in his chat and Okay.
Uh he did blame me for that call apparently,
dude.
at the very least, it sounds like he didn't check with his lawyers
after we found out she was a minor.
Dude, I nothing he's doing is with legal knowledge or with like
legal advice. There's just no way, right? Like, it seems pretty
clear to me that there's just no way you could think that.
So, do you think Destiny is going to get the death penalty in
Florida for C7 being a No, I don't think he'd get the death
Are you are you trying to like str I I don't even know.
I think the the dream has materialized. Okay. That this is the
dream. Oh, just being funny. Okay. Okay. The the dream has materialized
though. Okay. The dream has materialized. I believe it it's possible.
Okay. Some some registry might be possible. Possibly. Okay. Wait,
wait, wait, wait. What is Vigilance Stream saying? Uh, Vigilance
Stream.
He said, "I doubt he did anything criminal with respect to Rose."
Wait, Vigilance Stream. After he was after he was told by people
that she was under the age of 18, he apparently propagated pieces
of these videos into a group chat. Would that not be pretty clear
dissemination of CISAM? That seems pretty obvious to me. Unless
you talk about Solo, I actually missed your first message. So,
I wonder how it's going to look to a jury. The fact that he's
embroiled not only in the revenge, but now this at the same time.
Yeah. I Bro, he's not making himself sympathetic to a jury, is
he? He was told by the producer of the Cam, not just people.
That's also true. Yes. Oh, vigilance stream. Maybe I've seen
some people argue that
knowledge is required under the federal statute that it's not
just a statutory statute, right? I've seen some people argue
that. I do believe there's a there's a Florida statute that is
not that does not require that. But in any case, like I can we
can let judges or or cops or whoever look into that. I don't
really I don't know. I haven't looked into it yet. We could maybe
look into it later. Good message by Dungevil.
What is this? Hold on. Hold on. I mean, that's using an email
that we can't for confirm is real, but uh we'll see. We'll see.
I'll I'll look into that stuff a little bit later, guys. We should
go through the Willie video. Okay, let's get back to it. Let's
get back to it case. I've talked about it with my lawyer already,
specifically with regards to the Rose stuff. So, we went from
I don't know if I could delete this to my lawyer says it's totally
fine to keep. I don't know the law, but the idea that his lawyer
would tell him to hold on to CP for a civil case just doesn't
seem likely to me. I don't know. Law Tube can figure that out.
Three, if something were to come out of this, I don't know if
I'd want to wipe everything and not have something to turn over
to the authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political creator
is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about to hear
some weird. If hypothetically, her
dude boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her or getting
her to other dudes on video for him. And if there was ever some
kind of investigation into that, am I hurting the chance of looking
into him by deleting all of this stuff? Oh, so now the reason
he's keeping the CP is because of a hypothetical criminal case
that he is not pursuing at all. Okay. Maybe these >> and
and realistically if you've known, right, if you known she might
have been 17, I think you're you are morally required to pursue
that case then, right? If you think, well, because he's had this
thought in his head for a while. Well, if uh if she is underage,
then uh Solo is a really bad guy. Okay, why didn't you go to
the cops?
You can't you can't virtue signal over what a bad guy Solo must
be and also hold this evidence all to yourself hoping that it
never really blows up. That's wild. That's a wild practice to
>> These reasons are legally sound advice that came from
his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and just saying anything to make
it sound better to me. I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I just
know this guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 gigabytes
according to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he
doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong
somehow >> See, I know Destiny must have watched parts
of this video or he must have been talked parts of this video
must have been talked about cuz he gives evidence for this, right?
He just gives evidence for this one piece.
>> Destiny in the right. It makes no sense. For all he
knows, her boyfriend could have been 17 as well. Dude, you were
33. I reported this to the police and recorded my interactions
and calls with the detective. >> William, how you doing?
Is officer.
>> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great
question. >> Sure. screenshots or copies of the
>> of when you guys spoke about having teleport and all
that. >> I also sent them my DMs with Destiny. I don't
know if anything will come from this. I don't like leaking DMs
as me respecting what creators want on and off the record. Allows
me to talk to all sides of the situation builds trust with the
creator and also allows me to get By the way, just to be clear,
I Oh, man. I This is very interesting. Okay. Damn, he's stressed
AF. Destiny. Uh, he definitely is. He's definitely like been
leaking a whole bunch of stuff. Uh
me I dude >> followup statements for when the drama develops.
But when you tell me that you're in possession of and going to
remain in possession of C >> Well, that is funny.
Anna, well that is funny. Okay. We don't talk about Nathan here,
so keep it to yourself. Okay. Don't we don't talk about I understand
it's funny. I understand it's difficult. Okay. Oh, Willie stressed.
I see what you're talking about. Dorothy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
see it. I see it. I got it. EP, that confidentiality is over.
I shouldn't even need to say that. If Destiny ends up being legally
in the right to keep it, then fair enough. If he ends up getting
charged, then I'm glad I did something. I'm just trying to do
the right thing in a situation I've never been in before. >> Okay.
Well, will he call the cops? Um, I do believe you could call
the cops yesterday, the day before. Um, I know that the cops
have been notified with regards to Destiny's crimes. Okay.
I know things have been reported. We all know this. We've all
We all know this. Okay, we all know it. There will be H.
We move we move forward. Okay, where are we? What is this? All
right, give Willy something. What do you mean give Willie something?
Stalin a sloth. I mean, he gets credit for doing what I think
he was mandatorily legally required to do here. I do believe
he gets that credit. Yeah, 100%. Give me two seconds here. Yeah,
I know. I know, guy. Guys, the anoke was funny, but we we still
have the same principle. Okay, same principle applies. It's going
to keep applying. All right.
It's going to keep applying. So, Destiny was obviously rattled
today, not just from the Willie video, but from a lot of stuff.
He um he suggested he made some suggestions. Okay. About how
Sorry. He made some very open-ended suggestions about how to
stop people like Quimman or I. All right. Maybe Hamster. Maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe. All right. I'm not going to speak too much in that direction
for now. Okay. But we have these uh these these logs from Destiny
here earlier this morning. Okay. I thought this was um I thought
this is pretty crazy. All right. I I thought this is pretty crazy.
Ma Katarina in DG chat says, "I feel like JTock and Queen will
never stop and they have no content of their own, so they can
dedicate 24/7 to this. Not sure how one would stop that." Okay.
Destiny responds. Mia Katarina, uh it'll just come down to other
communities, especially this one, not being
about everything. She says, "True. was unbelievable how quickly
people ran with old KF info.
Not old at all. Was not old. Was not old at all. And see, this
is the part of the spin, but it's fine. Okay. Redhead says, "Destiny,
when you say not being, what do you mean exactly? Genuinely curious."
You know, Katarina follows up. I just hate Jtock and want him
destroyed. Wow. Fair. Uh, Redhead, you know what I mean, baby.
Destiny, when you say not being, what do you mean exactly? Genuinely
curious. You know what I mean, baby? Desty, in my heart of hearts,
I do.
Uh-huh. I don't, dude. I don't uh I like this pretty this pretty
wild. Okay. And people would maybe compare this I think people
would want to compare this to the Queenman Max Striker thing,
right? Where it's like somebody says, but that's not what's happening,
right? Destiny is opening this up and saying something's got
to be done about these people. And other people are filling the
blanks and he's going, "Yeah, buddy. Yeah, you know, you know
what has to be done. Like, huh? People need to stop being such
a [__] when it comes to these guys. Huh? What do
you mean? You know what I mean. I do know what you mean, right?
That's
That's crazy.
That's That's crazy. And it's not close to what uh what happened
with Quean. It's not close to anything Hassan's done. There's
just no there's no equating what he's doing, what he's actively
campaigning and doing to any other creator, right? He is just
openly calling for other creators to get killed. He's pointing
his audience at them. He's trying to, right? And I think this
is indicative of his state of mind that he has a obviously he
knows he's pretty [__] right? Oh, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Read my last message. Hold on. Vigilant stream. Give
me a second. I trust you. By the way, to clarify, DG misrepresentation.
Traffic cases of minors are not sealed in Illinois. The fact
that the case is public does not mean she was an adult. Furthermore,
the traffic violation resulted in a civil case in which Rose's
mother was served. This only happens if she was a minor. She
was 100% under 18. Oh, that's actually super helpful. Vigilant
stream, thank you.
Yeah, so her mother was served instead of her for a traffic violation.
I'm guessing that the ticket wasn't paid. And that only happens
if she's below 18. Oh, so that's like game, set, match. That's
game ball. That's That's it. That's It's over. It's Is it over?
Might be over. Destiny is booking a flight to Canada as you speak.
Uh I think he's probably booking a flight somewhere else. Okay.
Preferably somewhere with very very restrictive extradition policies.
Okay. Possibly Israel. Possibly Israel. Look at B. Yeah, I know
about the bad empanada tweet. I know. I know. I know. I know.
I know. I know all about it. One second. Oh, one second here,
guys. Sorry. I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Hello. Isn't the Tinder
proves she is overage as good as saying the minor was holding
a beer, therefore it's normal to assume 18 plus? Yeah, basically.
Is it even that strong? It's it's probably that's about the same
thing. Libo gaggins. Yeah. That like you see somebody holding
a beer and you're like, "Well, they would have served her alcohol."
It's it's the exact case that like come
>> Hello. Hello.
Hello.
How's it going, guys?
How we doing today? How we doing? How we feeling? How's it going?
What's up? What's up? What's up? It is Saturday, August 23rd.
Welcome back, guys. Welcome back. What an apicious
day.
Again, it's it's just every day is a a brand new day. It's a
beautiful day. I love it. I love it. I love it. Waking up is
a treasure. I treasure every day. Hello, Jayto. Hello, RPotter.
Hello, this school. Okay,
me reset some meters here and we are locked in. We're good to
go, guys. What's been going on? What's new? I saw a bunch of
people posting about the Viewbot stuff. Probably going to check
out some of that. We'll see. We'll see. Uh other than that, there's
like a bunch of uh for for better or worse, Destiny literally
can't hold to his word. He said, "Oh, I have to stop commenting
on this entirely because of my legal cases," which is not true.
This is not affecting his legal cases. Was it wasn't affecting
his legal cases. Could affect some criminal case against him,
but the legal cases he's talked about wouldn't.
So, we'll see. Misk lost like half his viewership. That could
be very funny. I heard Teone lost a lot. I heard nobody's been
a bigger victim than Meera. Okay. I I've heard Meera may be the
biggest victim of the Viewbot shutdown. Meera had a racket going
and and she's been shut out entirely. All right, that's what
I'm hearing. Hold on. What is this? Nick Wick Lee clip. Let's
check it out. What does Nick got for us? Kick, of course, doing
its infamous totally the bed. You know, kick totally the bed.
Why not? Let's see.
>> Uh Geeky Candy, thank you for the five gifted. Thank
you. Thank you. Let me start this timer here as well. Thank you.
Thank you, Geeky Candy. Appreciate the support. Hold on. We got
a Nick Wickly clip here. Can I Can we switch? Can my OBS work
for two freaking seconds?
There we go. Oh, snap. Here we go. We're reloading. We're reloading.
>> I see that. >> What is that supposed to mean?
I've been >> This is just frozen again. Dude, I I might
just have to I might just have to say no kick clips during stream
now. Like, you're going to have to download kick clips and send
them through something else cuz if they just always >> See
that? disaster. So, >> if they just always break or they
take like four attempts to load, I get too frustrated actually.
I just get too >> So mean. >> I've been cancelled
like half a dozen >> Isn't those are like 12? >> Yeah,
it's like six times. >> Left hand.
>> For what reasons? >> Uh mostly for domestic violence
abuse.
>> That's not even that bad. Dude, the bird landing Dude,
the bird landing on his shoulder like he's wife beater Cinderella
is so perfect right here. That's hilarious,
>> dude. Look at the timing. >> For what reason?
>> Uh, mostly for domestic violence abuse.
>> That's not even that bad. >> I know.
What's the not the only >> Dude, that's not even that bad.
>> I know.
That was uh that's a good clip. That's a great clip. What other
clips? I had this really clip up. Really the reaction from yesterday.
We can watch a little bit of this or something. Maybe a little
bit later. Oh, guys, there's a blastoff tweet. It's pinned in
the chat. Like the blastoff tweet. Engage with the blastoff tweet.
Retweet the blastoff tweet. Okay, let's go. Seriously, Omegle
stream was hilarious and I hate Nick. Yeah, I'm sure it was.
Nick is Nick can be funny. Absolutely. Did you see that legal
mindset covered the Willy Mac video on Destiny? No, I've totally
not been linked that a trillion times. Yeah, I I saw it. I saw
it. I've got it linked to me a bunch of times. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Love that. Really is Re was never defending Destiny.
JNNX. He was literally never defending the guy. I don't know
why people think that. That literally never happened. You have
to not be able to pay attention to the words and the meaning
of words to think that. But anyway, okay. Let me let me check
this clip out real quick. Is this the Lubu tweet? No. Oh, dude.
This is okay. Did this Did they actually make this? There's no
way they made this, right? This had to be a Max Striker special.
I saw this clip. I saw this uh meme as well. No, you the [__]
I am victim. The [__] Hassan is victim. Philip DeFranco.
Some non great thoughts from the and
fans. Destiny. Evil for want Hassan.
Hassan never lie. Evil for wants. Ela and Ethan, you are taking
their bait. Dude, this is this is perhaps Dude, I have a hard
time not getting a little I you know where my brain goes immediately.
I'm going to immediately do the Indian accent and like do we
have to do it? Do we have to do it? This is like did somebody
pay for this or is this just this this can't be real? This can't
be this can't be real. It can't be real. Do the needful Dude,
I All online engagement at this point is astroturfed by people
of different different origins. Okay, it's all astroturfed. It's
all fake. It's all It's all I don't know. Whoever made this meme
is deeply mentally ill. I would say so. Yes. Did you see the
food shops thumbnail? No. I don't watch food shops. I don't know
how people do that. I really don't get it. Um like honestly the
content is just all worse. Yeah. I just I don't get how people
do it to be honest with you. But you know, it is what it is.
Billy's always been skeptical of big claims and narratives. He
was just being consistent. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Let's
see what he Let's see how he reacted to this real quick. replies
>> I think it's just obvious that Destiny either didn't
follow his lawyer's advice or he didn't inform his lawyers correctly,
right? I think that's just very clear. That's obviously what
happened. That's got to be what happened, right? That's just
that is 100% all that could have possibly happened there. Like
there's no way. And he is saying otherwise, by the way, which
realistically somebody joked that Andrew Breler could have a
defamation case there. That seems possible. Okay, he's not asking
his lawyers because he's cheap. He might have asked his lawyers,
"How do I preserve evidence? Do I have to preserve everything?
How do I do that?" He might have said that, right? But I guarantee
he didn't say, "Oh, I have suspicions that this is Cam. Do I
need to do something different with it?" I don't believe that.
I don't I don't think that happened, man. I don't think it happened.
We could see, but I don't think so. Oh, boy. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Cyber Drifter, I believe this is the case that like there's definitely
some info left out there. Definitely some info left out there.
Um, let me see here. Uh, okay. All right. We're We're done with
this. Oh, there's one other clip I want to do, and we could probably
get right into stuff. Honestly, I'm going to give people a little
time to roll in, but we're doing some We get pretty quickly get
right into things. You got uh if you got relevant links, you
got funny links, you got some stuff you want me to see, okay?
You send them along. You send them to me, I'll uh I'll put them
up. Okay. Meme for stream. >> Dude, what is happening with
the audio here? Oh, it's all >> could be attractive to
you at your age. >> hold on. We going to start that over
from the beginning. >> One last question.
Would you be willing to say that postpubescent 13year-olds
could be attractive to you at your age? Now, I don't know. Um,
how about you? Go find all of the hottest 13-year-olds that you
can find. Collect a bunch of pictures of them and then send them
to me and I'll tell you if I think they're hot or not. Okay.
>> That's bordering on Tom being funny. That's that's bordering
on Tom being funny. I'm just telling you that's that's a clear
joke. You guys should toy about that. It's a clear joke. He obviously
does not want pictures of 13-year-olds. I'm sorry. That's that's
just a joke. He shouldn't be joking when he's also defending
a bunch of the other stuff he's doing, but that one's a joke.
When he was talking about the 17-year-old, that was not a joke.
Okay, that was not a joke at all. That was just true. Try not
to soy about uh trying not to about clear jokes, okay? Doesn't
look good. Speaking of, we'll be covering some stuff about that
today. Okay. Sewing about clear jokes, dude. There's There's
absolutely some sewing about clear jokes going on. And uh it's
not great. All right. It's not great. It's not good. It's not
awesome. Uh where is the NSE stream? She said she would go live
at 6 Eastern. No shot. She said she was going live. I feel Dude,
I don't know about that one, man. Really? We got Natsuite. She's
She's stepping up to the plate. She had a post on YouTube. Yeah,
but is it about something else? And she like maybe didn't know
about this or some [__] here. Hold on. Uh, believe
BB Poison linked this one, so we got to watch it.
What is this? What is this? What is this? I would ban BB Poison
from everything except I think he's got higher roles than me
in the Discord now. Technically, he is the highest role in the
Discord. So, he knew he had immunity and that's why he did it.
He knew he had immunity. He knew he could do it. This guy, get
him out of here. Get him out of here. All right.
Yeah, I I I think Soapbox, she might not have heard about how
far things had gone. She probably had heard about the Willie
video. Maybe possibly, dude. [__] you, BB Poison.
Why would you do that? Why would you do that to me? Why would
you do that? That's crazy. All right. She wasn't kicked in the
head by a horse. She would actually be super smart and go live
and set TTS at $5 and she'd make $500 plus from Ri alone. Four
of being called Gizlane for 2k is worth. Maybe. Yeah. Wait, Lauren
Southern and Lena unfollow Destiny. Maybe. Does that mean anything
to me? All that signals is I don't want heat for this. Ah, no
thank you. No thank I don't want the heat for that. Don't give
me heat for that. What? What? No. No thank you. That's really
all that means. Doesn't really mean anything else. Okay, let's
see. Someone's linking this. Hi, new friends, old and sweet little
goblins. I've been away too much uh for for much too long. I
am aware
uh in the last So, this isn't talking about why I should be going
live and I'm guessing tune in. Looking forward to hearing from
you. Including included some photos from Renfair in Bristol.
Wow, that's crazy. She was at the Renaissance Fair in Bristol.
Cool. So, I don't know. Maybe she just doesn't know why. Why
this seems like uh nothing. So, she I don't I don't know that
she really this seems to be saying that she's going to go live
and talk about this. And I feel like she has to know that she
can't go live and not talk about it, right? Like there's no option
to go live and not say [__] So, she might not have
been totally aware of what had happened. Oh, is she still posting
on Twitter? I just meant when she made this post, which was a
day and a half ago. Might not have been a lot. Might not have
been aware, but maybe she's been posting through it on Twitter.
And if she has, then I don't know. It's funny how she'll walk
both lines, though. It's It's just weird how she'll constantly
walk both lines of like, "It's actually misogynist for you to
hold me responsible for Destiny's opinions." That's actually
misogynist of you to hold me responsible like like I'm affiliated
with Destiny or I'm responsible for Destiny. But then
she gets in like one Tik Tok debate
and she just starts like throwing Destiny's wait name around.
>> How do you feel about Destiny?
>> Um I think he's a rather intelligent person. I just
think he's like an ed. >> That's what I'm saying. Like
you should >> rather intelligent person. I just think he's
like an edge. >> That's what I'm saying. Like you should
join us. Like seriously, you're I think I think you have great
>> I don't I don't know why I don't >> I know you
I know you hate me. That's okay. You don't you can hate me, but
like the rest of us hate >> you. I don't know who you are.
>> That's fine. But like honestly though, like if you think
Destiny is intelligent, I think you should join us. >> No,
because you're not intelligent. >> Sorry, I linked these
clips to somebody today. They said they were having some argument
and I just wanted to watch them again on stream. Honestly, I
just like these clips. These clips are funny. Wait, but Steven
is the headliner of all of the Unfuck America tour. >> You
think he gives a [__] >> dude? The optics of
trying to recruit girls to this America tour. Okay. The optics.
The Oh my god. I'm sorry. That's rough. That is rough. Okay.
>> Are you? >> Yeah. That's
>> I don't I don't see why >> I'm I'm Steven's business
partner for one. That might be important. >> I'm sure I'm
sure that's what you call yourself right now. But I >> No,
we own 5050. >> Even though Even though it is the Even
though it is the case that he's >> No, I am his business
partner. We own 50/50 at a company.
Okay. There's one more. You all know the other one. You all know
it. You all know it. >> You're kind of based. We're trying
to recruit you. >> Based in what? I haven't said anything.
>> You said that Steven was intelligent. That is Loki based.
>> He is. You don't you don't debate and not have like
a high level of intelligence or like an understanding of how
those types of conversations work.
>> What if I told you his job literally requires his intelligence?
I wouldn't deny that. >> What if I told you that Steven
regularly has said that Kyla or not so aridite is really good
at debate and does a really good job.
>> No way. >> Is he God? I I I don't Is he God? I
>> Dude, the person cannot stay on screen. They're just
laughing their ass off.
>> Okay. What? I don't care. >> Oh, okay. Do you
>> Amazing.
Amazing stuff. You love to see it. Okay. I don't think it carries
the same weight, Cherry. I don't think I have a reputation for
being particularly funny, so fortunately doesn't mean much.
Not a good endorsement. Okay, we got if we get some people on
today. Okay, we got some avatars going. All right, we got some
avatars going. This is our Augie RFC.
Okay, Top Bronson been hard at work. Top Bronson been very hard
at work. Okay, showing the whole lineup of possible people coming
on the stream. We got Queenman's inner pole. Quan doesn't even
get to be FBI. Queen gets to be inner pole. How cool is that?
The Queenman one's really good. Uh the Benny one is also pretty
good. Okay,
some good stuff. Some very cool stuff. VX77, that's not what
it is. Uh and these are actually pretty cool. Go back to the
cherry one. It's really cool. Uh, it is very good. Yeah. Boom.
Does this count as impersonation?
What do you mean? You can use that avatar for both Queenman and
Aiden.
You have to you have to make the hair dark if you want it to
be Aiden. Okay. You got to make the hair dark and then maybe
you're right. You could be right. All right. All right. All right.
What else are we doing here? Am I pulling more tweets up? Give
me a second. I'm just I'm very chill at the start of the stream.
Okay. Very very very chill.
Oh, let me pull this queen tweet up.
Dude, you wouldn't believe it. Okay, hold on. This is Destiny
talking about Willie Mac's wife. Oh, I should go through all
of this actually. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, cuz I believe
I believe Nicholas got mad about this. Hold on. Let me pull the
Nicholas tweet up. Let me pull it up. Let me pull it up. Is it
Nicholas saying that this is Destiny attacking? Yeah, Destiny
is now targeting at Willie Mac Show's wife.
Oh, you you guys care about Destiny targeting people's significant
others now? Is that something we actually pretend to care about?
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Let's read Let's read the comments here and see how badly Destiny
is attacking Willy Mack's wife. When I was in Israel a year and
a half ago, the MSAD did actually want to hire me for propaganda,
but I said it would be way too obvious. They offered me a cutiepie
in exchange for it, but I said my Viveance arc made me made it
not appealing. I didn't want to say anything, but I noticed that
exact same Israeli agent they were offering me just so happens
to be Willy's new wife. I don't want to leak this, but now I
will, I guess. Oh, sorry. I It was top to bottom, but Right.
Right. I'm sorry. You can hate Destiny as much you as you want.
That's clearly a joke. He's clearly not actually attacking anybody.
This is just a This is just a meme. This is obviously just a
meme. And they go, "Oh, Destiny is now attacking Willie Maxo's
wife."
Bro, come on. You can't You can't flip this hard when somebody
like says something about you when you guys go this hard that
hard on everybody else. Okay. When that's like a clear joke.
Oh, it's a cutie pie. Don't worry about it. I'm just telling
you that's clearly a joke. You look supery. You just give Desi
like it out. You look supery there. No, Zezy. You can you can
load this as much as you want. It's still just incredibly soy.
It's incredibly soy to to Zoy out about this. It is. It is. It
is.
But Queen comes in with the uh everything Destiny is saying here
is true, lol. which makes it so much better. Okay, that makes
it so much better, doesn't it? Everybody understands the reference.
Every everything Destiny says is saying here is true. Lol.
We remember
now. You don't have to believe me, okay? You don't have to believe
me, but I swear to God, I I told Jerry, I said, I wish Nicholas
didn't have me blocked so I can go and reply to this with the
Willie Mac Show tweet, right? I wanted to go do that. I said
this and then I said, "I'll just I'm just going to go tweet it
anyway. I'll just like take a picture." And I walked over to
my computer and refreshed Twitter and 3 seconds. Okay, it was
like a 5-second old tweet from Queenman was this. I was like,
"You piece of [__] You You beat me. Beat me by like
5 seconds." All right. Was up. He's in your walls. Many such
cases. Many such cases. I was I was just a funny little thing
that I was like, "Oh,
it's just a good tweet. Just a good tweet, that's all." Okay,
we're rolling. We're rolling. We're rolling. Where are we headed
first? We all joked about this one last night, guys. Okay, we
all joked about this last night. All right, Destiny goes to DG
DG chat last night and says, "I'm just done talking about everything
until the case is over. There's literally zero reason to do it.
Either bad faith actors in the Juice Doctor KF community will
try to weaponize everything or try to virtue signal like Willie
Mack and Ethan will just try to demonstrate their virtue to people.
I'm just done commenting. He says before spending the entire
night commenting, the entire next day commenting, right? Like,
who who do you think you're fooling, bro? Who do you think you're
actually fooling when you say this? We all know that you're not
going to stop. We all know that you're incapable of stopping,
right? We know that you're incapable of stopping. Why lie to
yourself? Q. Seven tweets, 24 replies, 96 blocks, and 40 minutes
on stream. Yeah, exactly.
Sorry, we're getting some tweets in as well. Years ago, Destiny
was friends with super famous mainstream Twitch streamers like
Pokemon and Lily Pichu. These days, he talks to food shops off
stream. Hey, just a year ago, he had connections to Ben Shapiro,
Tim P, Candace Owens, whole bunch of major political commentators.
What happened to that, too?
Destiny Food Shops looking at evidence offstream. Bro, what do
you think? Food Do you think he was linking?
We all thought he was linking the transcript. Maybe he was linking
something food chops was much more interested in. Who knows?
Who knows? Now, I I'm not making a claim there, okay? I'm just
I'm just hypothesizing. I'm just asking questions. Okay? I'm
just asking questions. That's all. That's all. That's all. That's
all. All right. So, we had we had this this is uh Substance.
I believe it's simply substance in in chat here, right? I believe
this is the same Substance. Simply substance in the chat. He
he tweeted this and he posted this last night, I believe, as
well. A couple people were posting this just like there's no
way. And of course, last night, Destiny did go and make multiple
comments. Okay, after that after that he went to the YouTube
video for Ethan Klein. Okay, Ethan Klein's YouTube video on Destiny
and says, "Insane to see the guy spamming lawsuits at people,
reading a totally unrelated set of DMs, pretending they were
the to the same person. I've never contacted the Rose person
on IG at any point in my life, but this guy and his suckup crew
are just chuckling along as they read off leaked revenge me."
Very high moral standards, I guess. We're just desperately trying
to cater to the audience. Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z Z.
So, Destiny drops that comment on the YouTube video. I believe
Ethan Klein's first response is actually fairly reasonable. Do
I have Ethan Klein's first response here? Yeah. Yeah. Oh, hold
on. I don't have it. Hold on. I'll grab it real quick. Ethan's
first response, I believe, is something along the lines of uh
if I got something wrong, feel free to point it out. I believe
that's what it is, if I'm not mistaken.
Let me see if I can grab it here. I don't have it. It's something
along the lines of,
hey, if I got something wrong, then you feel free to correct
it, but like I don't think I got too much wrong here. If I got
a lot wrong, go ahead. Right. Destiny's focused on these DMs,
which were highlighted at the very end, right? Oh, chuckling
along as they read off of leaked revenge me. Very high moral
standards, I guess. Dude, this this kind of annoys me when he
talks about leaked revenge, right? when he talks about leaked
when he has leaked on other people multip I believe multiple
times. No, like did he not leak those denim sex? I I don't know
how he could get off leaking those denim sex and then saying,
"Oh, this is leaked revenge for me." When it goes to those DMs
from the British person, but this is him responding in the YouTube
comment. Okay,
there's a couple things going on around this. All right, couple
things going on. Oh, this got deleted. No way. I believe his
unpopular opinion. And I believe this is somebody basically defending
Destiny. Hold on. Anyway, we go we go back and forth. Ethan Klein
posts some responses. Okay. Says, "Hey, go ahead. Show me what
I got wrong." Right. Oh, hold on. We don't go back and forth
yet. We don't go back and forth because I forgot Destiny last
night. Oh, I'm forgetting the time progression. Okay. Oh, boy.
Destiny last night decided to throw this this shot across the
bow at Ethan. Okay, this is the crazy one. This is much longer.
Crazy. I mean, there are some jokes in here. It's a mix. He is
obviously angry at Ethan, right? Obviously really pissed Ethan.
He had an understanding. Okay. He had an understanding with Ethan.
Hey, Ethan. We're going to totally pretend that like all criticism,
we're just going to lump that all in with snarkers, right? We're
both going to do that and then we won't ever call each other
out for like for trying to use this snark community to to silence
all criticism against us. We're both going to do it. We have
an understanding, right? And then Ethan totally took some stuff
from Destiny A logs and was presenting it because it's facts,
right? The facts about Rose are there. It's It's She was 17 and
Ethan used it and Destiny feels betrayed. They had an understanding.
Okay. All Snark posting. All Snark is bad. All Stark is evil.
So the first two sentences full on admitting he had CP in his
possession. No way. Almost everything in this DM is wrong. Willie
Mack is running cover. I think he means uh Oh, hold on. This
goes back to this, right? Almost everything in this DM. >> Oh,
right. This is the first one. This is the first response. >> This
is the first donated $5. I realized he's because he's relying
on his attorney's advice, but they only advise him on the narrow
purview of the Pixie case. He likely has no criminal attorney
advice with some possibility. He is too to get one till >> um
No, I think he could easily ask those lawyers for advice. I think
he did ask for advice from those lawyers or his lawyers in New
York, whichever ones, but I believe he left out the the fact
that it was potential cam because otherwise I assume we would
have seen some action there, right? That's That's just facts.
Thanks for the five, though. So, this was this is the one. So,
is the claim that the DMs are yours, but with someone other than
Rose? Do you deny having a 17-year-old's nudes on your computer?
And he says, "Almost everything in these DMs is a lie." Almost
everything in this DM is wrong. Willy Mack is running cover because
he wants to get in with the boys again. 911. Sorry, let me call
back. My OBS wasn't recording. Lol. It is a little weird. It
is a little weird that that call is recorded. I I guess. lie.
It is what it is. It's a YouTuber. Okay. It's a YouTuber.
>> Uh, Funky Boss, thank you for the 16 months.
Is there like some concern there that I don't know. I
never mind. It's fine. It's fine. I won't comment too much on
it. So, sorry. Let me My OBS wasn't recording. Please call me
back. And Ethan is trying to distance himself from me because
he's too weak to deal with Hassan's attacks against him, using
me as a vector since he has literally nothing of substance to
contribute in this area. Hassan's lack of intelligence is his
biggest insecurity that no amount of finasteride, hair dye, or
bathtub photo shoot will compensate for. Okay. Um, just seething
about Hassan having a full head of hair and
Hassan literally keeps the gray in, right? So, full head of hair
and his GQ just openly seething, transparently seething about
Hassan,
right?
Like there's just there's no actual criticism here. Hassan's
Hassan's not that smart. and and
he he cares about his appearance. What a loser.
>> Uh Downey, thank you for the 7 months. Let's go. I have
no cam on my computer. I've only compiled or sorry, I've only
complied with my legal obligations for my court cases. The 60
GB screenshot was related to a claim the Rose person made. Someone
whose name and birth date have yet to even be reliably confirmed.
No, they have been reliably confirmed. They've been reliably
confirmed at this point.
Right. Absolutely. They have 60 gigabyte screenshot was related
to a claim the Rose Bros person made. Yes. So this is of course
him trying to claw on to the idea. I think we described this
yesterday guys. The 60 gigabyte number that is pointless, right?
This is a pointless number to focus on. You shouldn't focus on
it. What you should focus on is that Destiny appears to have
taken a screenshot from VC media player of what he is saying
must be CSAM, right? What we now know must be seam. And he sends
that to Willie Mac. That is the concerning thing he's done, right?
I don't have CM on my computer. I believe what he's saying, Ozel,
is that he has archived it and held it in in hard drives somewhere
else or something, right? I think that's what he's saying. Now,
unfortunately, him holding it on his own has led to him sending
uh like archives like artifacts of that Cessam to other people.
Seems like he's admitted this directly.
Very bad. Very not good, right? But he's trying to focus on the
60 GB thing because he he's pretending that makes a big difference,
right? This is why you should try to focus on the most important
questions. Destiny, did you in fact send artifacts of this child
abuse material to a group chat of 10 people trying to find the
person who you didn't believe was a minor, but had had reason
to be at least minorly suspicious. Okay, at least minorly suspicious.
So, I would say probably Destiny, if he's betting 50/50, he might
not have thought that was a minor, you know, more than 20%, 30%.
Unfortunately, that 20 or 30% is enough to go to the cops. Okay,
basically once you're informed, you kind of are bound to act
in my opinion. Okay, but that's why you should focus on those
questions because otherwise Destiny will try to weasle his way
through this and go, "Wow, 60 gigabytes. Look, that's what they
had. 60 gigabytes." I don't know what the why why did you guys
say I have 60 gigabytes? You just lied. You just lied about me.
A screenshot is 5 to 20. Maybe possibly. We'll see. We'll see
in the legal mindset video. Yes, guys. We'll get to the legal
mindset video. Don't worry. Don't worry. We'll get there. We
will get there. I promise we'll get there. Okay. I'm aware of
the legal mindset video and we will get to it. All right.
Ethan is literally reading off revenge leaks of mine and giggling,
coughing because he's too lazy to use his inhaler like a child
for DMs that had absolutely nothing to do with the rose leak.
any reference to or orgies or anything else was literally in
the context of DMs with a 26-year-old British person. I've never
DM'd uh I've never DM'd that rose person on IG in my life. Uh
what was that? Hold on. That was a another sub. Nope.
Say celebration. I'm going to turn down the kick alerts at the
very minimum. Kick alerts are going. No sound. Okay. I think
Peterson Oh, this is where he edited this. Okay, we'll get to
the edit after this. It wasn't This didn't end up being inflammatory
enough, guys. He had to edit this down. Okay, I only talked about
orgies with a different woman. Okay, I'm not going to yuck other
people's yums. You can talk about that with an adult. Okay, you
can go ahead and talk about that with an adult. Whatever. Kind
of [__] that that would get leaked or something,
but I don't know. Couldn't have happened to a couldn't have happened
to a nicer person. Okay, I think Peterson was right about Ethan
and Nila. you Zionist and genocide supporter in the United States
with loyalty to Israel first and Ela genocidal IDF maniac nightwriting
innocent Palestinians in the West Bank because she wasn't seeing
enough bloodshed at her desk job writing pardons for IDF rapists
deserve all the CPS calls for the dog eating claims and everything
else. You deserve zero sympathy from anyone else on the internet
when you're so quick to turn around and rely on the same snark
snarks. Snarkers are there. Guys,
just any negative opinion of me is Snark now. Any negative opinion,
that's Snark. Is it a fact? Is it just a fact? Is Was it a fact
that she was 17? Yeah, but it's Snark. Don't look at it. It's
Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark. It's Snark.
Okay. When you're so You deserve zero sympathy from anyone else
on the internet. when you're so quick to turn around and rely
on the same snark that's been plaguing you for years as soon
as you think it's beneficial. I hope your prior maid takes you
for a mill in her lawsuit against you guys as well. Waving for
anyone else watching, you should assume that every single influencer
person you meet on the internet is a terrible human being with
zero values or principles. See you tomorrow for the stream.
So Ethan dropped this video last night. Uh Destiny responded
to it, right? And Ethan had two comments. Okay. is the claim
that the DMs are yours but with someone other than Rose. Do you
deny having your 17-year-old's nudes on your computer? And there
was one more response here from Ethan, I believe. Okay, so he
gets this comment from uh when he purports to be a DJ, I believe.
Uggh. It's just so tiring when someone who's being vilified and
lied about as much as Ethan falls for some pretty obviously fake
DMs just because it aligns with a narrative that is also likely
missing so much information. This is a weird virtue signal video.
IMO, this virtue signal thing is going to be like a major uh
PDF dog whistle going forward. Destiny has set the narrative
that like, oh, this is just people are just virtue signaling
because they're scared of snark communities, so they're just
virtue signaling. You hear somebody call this virtue signaling,
that's a major PDF dog whistle. Okay.